[Music]
last thing I googled was his Wyoming on
the Pacific Ocean and I found out for
them but it's not his Kylie Jenner
pregnant
I googled where do I find quaaludes
there are like discontinued like
prescription drug have you ever seen the
wolf of Wall Street
those are quaaludes I have serials like
Siri where do I find quaaludes Ursula's
full story from the Little Mermaid top
ten strip clubs in Las Vegas the San
Diego Viking festival they have like a
combat there and stuff these weapons
earlier I had I was reading an article
on East so huh I guess that's pretty
interesting
I googled cars land during Halloween
great black wasp which parasitizes
caterpillars it lays its eggs inside the
caterpillar the eggs develop into larvae
and they know what portions of the
caterpillar to eat to keep the
caterpillar alive the longest before
they hatch into little bee
disciple how to make jello shots out of
pickles and
you know molest google history search
was that Coppertone baby that had the
dog pulling down her pants we couldn't
remember which which suntan lotion it
was it's so funny we call it suntan
lotion there you go that I'm from the
80s right there
my grandma's husband mistakenly said the
word Brundle instead of grunion so he
looked up what grundle meant and
possibly I knew it it meant but my
sister and her boyfriend didn't know
that meant the area between the scrotum
and the penis and on a mouse so we
googled what is a grundle what is a
sundae as in the ice cream I I couldn't
just I couldn't figure out what it was
so I had to do that and it took me about
ten minutes to find out what it actually
was
what type of names have you wrongful I
guess I was using the voice search and
it didn't go shoes
you know some Jordans electric long
boards because I'm I here with my
longboard just pushing all day long
figured I could use a break I googled
Khan Academy it's a free learning
website where you can learn all kinds of
things so right now I'm learning how to
do mathematics starting from a third
grade level on because I don't remember
any of that stuff the chords from a
Hillsong song a Hillsong group called
from the inside out but what I was doing
was actually getting songs to use for
our Sunday morning service
it was silhouettes of dogs because I'm a
metal artist and I was doing a piece on
my latest piece was a dog looking up at
a UFO coming in and it's called dogs
know it's not a really cool spider on my
front porch last night so I wanted to
figure out what it was so I googled
Southern California garden spiders that
I didn't brother better
- her ballot I was trying to find the
how to put on contouring with this
makeup palette that I had I'm using on
you I'm you
[Music]
thing I did was to Google prostate
cancer medicine called site eegah
because my husband Gary's had prostate
cancer it's expensive it's a few
thousand dollars a month think the
different shirts probably cover it all
but you know what if it has more time
for me being with him is well worth
[Music]